whenever there's uncertainty in markets
or some sort of chaos in the world
people always ask what is the best safe
haven asset as we saw during the
pandemic during 2020 and the economic
recession that followed ultimately
people decided to move towards a
decentralized digital currency bitcoin
exploding upwards in price now that
doesn't mean that every single time we
get uncertainty or chaos that bitcoin
would service the best safe haven asset
there's assets like gold that have
served as a safe haven for literally
thousands and thousands of years so
let's take a look at what's happening
during this ukraine russia conflict
ultimately bitcoin again proving to be
that safe haven in times of global
uncertainty it's outperformed every
other asset class by orders of magnitude
since the start of this conflict we see
here bitcoin compared to oil the s p 500
dgi gold and other assets bitcoin
continuing to prove to be that superior
asset now if we look just yesterday at
the moves in bitcoin these are material
double-digit percentage moves we had
almost a 15
gain in bitcoin's price yesterday it is
the largest one-day gain since february
8th of 2021 over a year ago and so
ultimately whenever you get an asset
that has the ability to move this much
in one single day people start to pay
attention and the question is why are
they doing this well yesterday the
treasury and other organizations within
the united states they banned any u.s
citizen or u.s company from doing
business with the russian central bank
there's economic sanctions that are
being levied from countries all around
the world on russia on russian citizens
and on the oligarchs and government
officials ultimately people are
realizing maybe an asset that can't be
debased away by anyone maybe an asset
that's censorship resistant or caesar
resistant maybe it's actually pretty
valuable that's what we're seeing right
here in price is that the market is
determining that bitcoin is more
valuable today in the eyes of that
market participant than it was just one
week ago and so we've got this tweet
here from suzu he makes a great point
where he says if you're the type of
person who only gains conviction in
bitcoin when it's going up and you lose
it when it's going down you actually
have no conviction at all you should
consider trying self-reflection and
self-respect now of course ultimately
what we are watching is the world waking
up to the idea of a decentralized
digital store of value and medium of
exchange bitcoin is inevitable in my
mind because every single person is
going to want some portion of their
economic wealth and their financial
portfolio stored in an asset that no one
can devalue and no one can seize hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time